and even Marvel was a little you know we
we we shot it and then I I heard that we
we weren't going to do that wow but it
was so great right and they're like you
know we got to do what Marvel says and
then the process went on and Marvel came
back and they're like you guys have
earned it oh that's
[Applause]
[Music]
incredible
we are here reject Nation with that's a
great question with me Coy jandro we are
here with Yuri lenthal one of my
favorite people in LA and someone who is
as big maybe bigger a Spider-Man fan
than me and I'm SOC we all know that's
not true I you're bigger than no you're
bigger than than than any other
Spider-Man fan uh you know bigger
Spider-Man fan than any other Spider-Man
fan by a queen smile well I the last
time I saw you before my birthday was
actually actually at the across the
spiderverse premiere and I think that
was my favorite Afterparty in history
because it was just Spider-Man fans yeah
it was it was the best did did you
mentioned to everyone that the only
reason I was at that Afterparty or that
screening at all was because I was your
plus one I am occasionally humble and
one of the humbleness that's also
Li that's fair that's fair let's be
honest and that's a great question but
yeah I I brought you uh to Spider-Man
because like I didn't think there was a
way to celebrate Spider-Man better and
that that Afterparty I think was like
what I what I see the legend of
afterparty like in the ' 80s and '90s
like Hollywood but it was all Spider-Man
fans it felt like a celebration of
Spider-Man yeah it felt very safe I
usually feel very unsafe at parties like
that I S hide in the corner and and I'm
afraid to talk to anyone but everybody
there was safe yeah and it was like
nerds in the front of camera meeting
like Bendis and slot and like Lorden
Miller wrangled I think the greatest
hits of spider fans yeah so I I've never
had a better time at Afterparty yeah and
and I met some people that I had never
met before that you would assume by then
I would have met yeah that was the first
time and the moments to in rodu like
voices of characters to their namesakes
and people that created them and see it
was like Mor poic but positive like this
is your father like it was such a joyous
time yeah Josh Keaton was there yeah
never met in person we talked online and
Josh is the light man yeah Josh Josh is
the best and and that was the first time
that I almost met Jack Quade and then
you sealed that deal and now we're
besties but he's like in so many photos
of us in the background doing like FPS
without you guys having met super photob
bombed us you Jack and Nicholas Cage are
the only three people on the planet to
be both Superman and Spider-Man I would
love somebody to to fact check that
claim but I think I'm right cuz I told
him that at uh a thing he was doing and
then at my birthday you guys were
talking about it and you cementing it
made me feel like it was true it's the
best club ever I mean you you could
argue that that it's you know they're
all Peter Parker because because
technically he's because Jack is Peter
Parker right not Spider-Man per se but
Peter Parker but we're we're all the
three of you have been Peter Parker and
Clark Kent and and Clark Kent so let's
yeah let's I mean it's it's a hell of a
club to Bel to and we should totally
have our own varsity jacket I think that
like team I would watch that show s
jacket it's like your beautiful D those
two I almost wore it today but I was
like it's a little toasty uh I have
these two jackets uh I Yuri was the
first person I sent it to they're I
can't believe you just found those at a
video store in Hollywood in Burbank but
I have these jackets that were a members
only jackets for people that were
Executives at Marvel and they only made
a hundred of each one of them is the
first Todd McFarlan art on a piece of
like tangible material and one is the
first black suit post secret ORS and
they're like beautiful but actually that
brings me to an important question with
the you Nick Cage Jack Quaid team uh
what do you see as the VIN diagram of
Clark Kent and Peter Parker like what
are their similarities and what are
their differences and your portrayals of
them oh that's good I mean I I think
both Clark Kon and Peter Parker believe
in the goodness in people I mean you
know it's it's it's it's part of their
their cores it's you know it's it's why
they do what they do and why they can
keep doing it every day yeah so I think
that's I think that's where the
crossover comes I mean I'm sure it's
other things to bad jokes is also you
know does also Factor although you know
Clark sometimes is serious to a fault
and and Pete doesn't know ever how to be
serious fair I mean it's it's covering
deep you know a well of deep
sadness absolutely but he doesn't know
how to stop uh cracking jokes and and at
least you know Clark knows you know he's
got to be serious sometimes so the key
difference you'd see is that Clark has
to be stoic at times and I think that
probably comes from his like overpowered
nature like he he has to find that
stability yeah yeah absolutely now when
you were doing Moa on the first game I
love that you were actually doing it and
getting to play were there any muscle
memory moments from doing gymnastics and
like going back to those days where you
like remembered your training at
Williams and Mary and like everything
like leading between the two you've done
your research that was that was that was
good um uh I I would I would love you
know I got the snarky reading that was
good it's like this Show's called that's
a great question I'm GNA give that was
good we'll see if he earns great that
was good um well you know you I mean
you've got a lot to live up to cuz we've
known each other for so long that's true
no I start that way I didn't get it
until like third act in the on the one
you about to see but I'll learn it okay
fair enough you know I would love to say
how my my gymnastics and martial arts
training really informed uh all the the
moves the cool sweet moves that I do in
Spider-Man uh but I the truth is I have
really good stunt doubles so so if you
know if it's a scene it's like a
cinematic you know a cut scene where
where Pete is being Pete or Pete is
doing something really you know bumbling
and nerdy that's likely me that's like
back like walking to the right right
exactly well the thing is is you know I
could have tried some of that stuff but
but I'm like older than I was when I was
in college doing gymnastics and even
when I was in college through gymnastics
I wasn't great so I you know I figured
this is one of those times where you
leave it up to the professionals but it
was but it was cool it was like a dance
you know shooting those scenes was like
I would do the scene up to a certain
point and then I would tag my stunky and
he'd come in and he'd you know get in
the position that I was in and then he
just take he dive out the window you
know literally so it was it was it was
this really cool dance making Spider-Man
out of several people and you got to
watch that in real time as a Spider-Man
fan that's one of my favorite things
about your love of Spider-Man is you've
gotten to live it POV wise more than
most and you've also like multiversity
been villains in Spider-Man what's it
like to watch someone be Spider-Man that
isn't you but also have to attack them
and yell at Spider-Man see that's it it
that we have such a weird job yeah um
and when you're a nerd it gets even
weirder yeah um because quantum theory
means like you both those things at once
that's true so so I am I am at times you
know Kurt Connor's and the lizard yes
but also uh Spider-Man all and Ben Ry
and Peter Parker issue 151 when they're
just brawling on that tast stack like
that's right you know and or and spider
cop oh D who's Canon Canon which is I
mean that was one of the greatest things
they ever did post you know that first
game yeah was to make spider cop Cannon
uh we had to immortalize that moment uh
because uh unfortunately he doesn't make
an appearance in uh in in two but I
think the comic book adaptation which
we'll get to is is plenty of of Lord
yeah yeah yeah without a doubt um I I I
keep uh you know you know I carry a
torch for that guy and I he deserves his
own DLC but but I don't know I don't
know that we'll see it Brian yeah right
right I know oh so sorry a question I
let when you're doing a voice of a
Spider-Man villain how disorienting is
it having played Spider-Man so long to
be someone attacking someone you're also
identifying with as uh you know it's
it's weird because I keep wanting to
step in when you know when there are
Spider-Man lines in the script or when
you know what's it um
and it's it's hard not to go would I
would I have said the line that way yeah
um but you know I mean luckily there's
so many different Incarnation so many
different projects and each you know
each project is different so the
Spider-Man in that world is a different
Spider-Man it's you know it's we
understand now the spiderverse it's a
different Spider-Man so it wasn't super
hard it was it was about as confusing as
yelling my own name in the Spider-Man
game because Yuri Watson AB you know I I
had to yell Yuri so many times which is
weird because my name is Yuri um and
then that the whole other layer of weird
gets added onto because I know that my
wife is playing that going to be the
voice coming back at you as Yuri right
did that ever happen in the booth did
you guys record together or did you not
know what that would feel like until you
heard it in playback we didn't record
together because uh so much of it was
gameplay and all the gameplay stuff we
record separately but we did have a few
scenes together you know for a s for
cinematics okay and it was always uh I
mean even in the room there was like
that's that's a Yuri line I'm like I
mean you mean one of my lines or or or
Yuri what are we talking about here do
they have a character Yuri label or they
just say Yuri and hope it worked out
they say Yuri and hope that's basic so I
I know working with her must be
incredible does it ever get to a point
where you guys are talking about stuff
at home and it naturally Blends into
work conversation and blends back in
like do you guys have a a dinner table
separation of church and state or do you
guys just let it flow I mean it's not a
we don't we don't have any rules as far
as that's concerned but um you know I'm
a lot nerdier than she is so it's it's
likely she's not going to bring it up at
home
we're certainly not against it yeah but
but usually she gets home and she's like
and now we're home and I'm like yeah but
Spider-Man she's like yeah you're
Spider-Man um good for you the costume
we both like the suit we both have so we
can feel like we're being adults but
also being Spider-Man is very important
for that sanity line totally like having
a tailored suit makes you feel like an
adult the only time that it ever that
she ever sort of Let it bleed in was
when I was doing Prince of Persia a long
time ago and it was one probably the
last time she touched a game console to
be honest uh but she she would get
frustrated with me and she'd go in the
other room and like jump the prince off
cliff
like it was because we don't fight well
like she and I are really bad at
fighting do you fight virtually she be
like excuse me and she'd and she'd walk
out and I'd hear you know I hear myself
you know screaming and then going no no
no that's not how it happened let me try
again oh that's amazing yeah I love the
virtual reality Matrix punishment of
like I'm going to I'm so mad yeah
exactly so with you playing Spider-Man
in this very specific tap like the
Insomniac Sony take I do feel like
there's only a few actors that when I
read a comic I hear the voice like Ryan
Reynolds dowy because they've made Tony
Downey but the Spider-Man comic
adaptation Insomniac that's 100% your
voice like I hear you when I read it
it's like you're Spider-Man what do you
think is the biggest distinguishing
factor of the Insomniac Spider-Man as
written and as portrayed that separates
him to you from 616 or 1610 I mean God
the just the the writing think I'm s
people must at this point think I'm
sucking up to the writers at this point
but he wants Spider-Man 3 right yeah if
you guys he going to recast right like
writers have any power over anything as
we all know writers the power level yeah
but the the writing was just so good and
I love that they chose not to do the
origin story again like we don't need to
do this we've seen it so many times
everybody knows you know that he got bit
by radioactive spider it was Goofy in
the beginning and then he you know fig
figures out and you know with great
power and all that that stuff so I love
that they said it a little later and I
love that they seem to have done a great
job at giving you know Insomniac has
been great at giving us all the things
that we love about a character we know
so well and yet turning it just a little
bit so that you're still on the edge of
your seat and you're like wait a minute
that's a surprise yeah like I didn't
think you know I had any surprises left
with Spider-Man um I was expecting it to
go like this because you're leading me
down this path that's so well worn yeah
and then there's there these little you
know things back and forth that you're
not expecting and and they're just
they're just brilliant at that I think
Spider-Man is one of the characters that
because he's so well worn and because
he's so archetypal we can have moments
like the Green Goblin subversion into
vulture in the Homecoming movie and we
can have the subversion with Doc O was
there a moment as a comic fan when you
first got sides on the first game that
really made you go like oh they're doing
that like were you surprised at at a
certain turn a couple couple surprises
uh you know that we we know that Doc O
story and we've seen it you know you
know we've seen in comics we've seen it
in movies you know and it's it's you
know arguably you know for a lot of
people that's you know their favorite of
the Toby McGuire Spider-Man films so for
them to to sort of take that I was I was
a little nervous I was like really are
we are we doing this but because it's a
game they have there's so much
connective tissue to get to that even to
that story yeah um you know there are
plenty of other villains not like they
haven't tried to cram a million villains
into a Spider-Man movie before problem
what are you talking about lean but also
the you know the May thing yeah that was
rough I mean that was and and I I guess
we can talk spoilers since the game you
just cated it's been five years and even
Marvel was a little you know we we we
shot it and then I I heard that we we
weren't going to do that wow they were
like they you know they don't they don't
want to kill Antman I'm like well I get
that but it was so great right and
they're like you know we got to do what
Marvel says and then the process went on
and Marvel came back and they're like
you guys have earned it like oh that's
incredible which is as I understand it
you know I hear things from a lot of
people and I don't know exactly what
went on behind closed doors but you know
there there were rumors that we weren't
get to going to going to kill yeah and
um and then it came back I love that
Spider-Man and loss are so integral to
each other and I I'd honestly say like
Gwen Stacy is the most important
Spider-Man character because I mean not
only did that start the Bronze Age of
comics and Silver age but her death is
what like changed Mary Jane from a party
girl changed Spider-Man into into
realizing things post Uncle Ben like
there's such a moment when when Aunt May
dies in the game that feels like when
Stacy to me yeah are there ramifications
and I don't want spoilers because I want
to play this game please I'm not even
gonna don't even ask for him audience in
commentary but I uh I don't want to hear
anything about the second game that
would be negative but when you were
making it did you feel that weight of
Aunt May like Gwen Stacy yeah yeah and I
I think not only did did I feel it you
know as as an actor who went through
that and experience you know and as a
character who you know experiences was
clear from that first game um but it's
it it plays a part in the story like it
really that weight is felt we couldn't I
I don't think we could do that and then
sort of pretend like it didn't happen in
the game or not refer to it or not let
it affect you know who Pete has become
and you know what what his his his goals
are now and you know just his his his
deepening well of you know issues Peter
Parker very very welltoo guy he's taken
care of he's just the most popular
exactly
all the m in the world a lot of dancing
that was also the bully McGuire dance we
got to do at a red carpet is maybe like
you know I had to life what people
wanted to see yeah it's the people
demanded it and then again at uh ComiCon
yeah I had to double down on that and I
didn't tell them table I didn't tell
them I was going to do it because I was
afraid that if I said that I was going
to do it they would tell me not to I saw
you right before like the moment you
about to go on stage cuz I had just done
the panel for I was like Bully McGuire
and you're like and then within minute
two did I was like it's Beau you got on
the table I was I'm just glad I didn't
fall off the table cuz that would have
been a whole different thing we will not
be doing moap for the remain of So
speaking of the live action Spider-Man I
don't personally like the who's your
favorite because that implies lesser and
I also think that especially with the
multiversal across the spiderverse
expansion they're all Canon they're all
their own thing but what are your
favorite attributes of each of the live
action Spider-Man as someone playing and
what do you look at each of them as
doing that you love most of those ones
oh man you know I you know I grew up
with Toby it's hard not to to think of
Toby there's something super vulnerable
about him yeah that I think Spider-Man
absolutely requires you know as a as a
character he's also very giddy with what
he gets to do you know once he sort of
gets past the the awkwardness of it he's
giddy with what he gets to do he never
saw himself you know getting to affect
the world in that way um so so I've
always loved that uh about Toby but
everybody's got and it it really only
came clear to me in no way home getting
to watch all three of them together and
how different they portray the same
character and how that character is that
versatile yeah I've said it before but I
would watch an entire movie of those
three Spider-Mans hanging out in a room
talking about whatever like I don't even
care they don't have to go they don't
have to go fight crime they don't have
to save the world yeah they just sit
around in the room you know and talk and
I would watch the [__] out of the scene
in the lab is one of the best like it's
so Spiderman it's so great and I didn't
know I love them all so much until that
moment I'm like yeah I've got my
favorite and and the other guys are
doing a great job and you know it's uh
and I love the reason you know movies
for different reasons but but it was it
was it was that movie that made me
realize how brilliant each of them are
I've always seen them and your portrayal
and Josh's portrayal and and all the
different ways they can be played as
like um different runs not even like
ultimate but like when Peter Parker's
coming out the same time as Sensational
same time as spectacular the same time
as amazing same time is you've got all
these different artists and inkor and
writers on a book and the the actors
feel like the artist incor and writer
shaping this character but with them all
in one thing it felt like that smash
page of like arter like jamming together
and like making those vibes but I wonder
for you is there an arc or an artist or
a writer any specific attribute that you
remember that helped shape your
Spider-Man that really was iconic to
your shape of who he is I you know
because I was I was so young when I got
into uh into Spider-Man I wasn't
thinking about that
but it was interesting with you know the
passing of John Rita Senor
recently they they showed a bunch of you
know a bunch of his art you know popped
up and I'm like that's I'm like growing
up those are the covers I remember
that's the art that I remember and
everybody's you know I had I had sort of
fallen out of reading you know
Spider-Man regularly you
know I'm trying to remember you know
exactly when it was but you know like it
was it was the early stuff that had like
the the most effect on me and you know
effect on who Spider-Man was to me and
Senior to me like him and and baggley
and McFarland like there's certain
artists that are different ages of
Spider-Man obviously when they did it
but like the the emotion in in remita
felt so Earnest and open and I feel like
that's you know the insomnia so
character yeah like I I had I think even
even before McFarland like I had stopped
reading regularly so obviously you know
it's iconic and and I I recognize it
immediately but when I was really keyed
into Spider-Man you know um it was yeah
it was it was it was before then so
there's something for everyone yeah you
know if if you if you really want to get
into Spider-Man there's a Spider-Man
there for you I see Toby as dicko yours
as Rita uh Garfield as McFarlin and
baggley is Tom that's like always my oh
wow cuz that to me they're different
shapes different flavors and I was so
worried about a Spider-Man game to be
honest because I was like this is going
to inform in a new generation and gaming
has become such a a formative part of
the Arts and it's so important that I
was like if they don't this yeah people
people were like you know so were you
just you know on Cloud9 for 3 years
while you were making this game and I'm
like no I was scared out of my mind that
I was going to ruin Spider-Man for
another for New Generation yeah right
exactly in post like you know Fallout
from yeah right exactly this this would
be like you know everything else is
great except for that that Spider-Man
from the game he's terrible I spent 30
hours to hate this character imely I
love swinging but I hate this guy every
time I play it on
face yeah and and that's what I find
interesting about the game is it did
have such a Major Impact I think because
of certain choices and The Bravery of
the the Doc O Choice the May choice and
all those things what have been some of
the conversations you've had with
Spider-Man fans because they are a very
vocal Bunch uh have you enjoyed the cons
enjoyed the immersion like what's that
been like to to receive that now that
the game's been out I love how
emotionally connected people you know
have have become to that Spider-Man yeah
uh you know I love that they say it's
one of their favorite Spider-Man stories
cuz when you think think of the bre of
Spider-Man stories I mean that's a
that's a big deal when somebody comes up
to me and says I hear your voice when I
read the comics now they don't know what
that does to me inside um you know or
you know you're my favorite Spider-Man
I'm like I I could because it still
feels like a dream that I have yet to
wake up from like this couldn't possibly
be happening um but I I I you know I've
loved the response you know I was I was
terrified for the longest time that I I
wouldn't you know that
I have to hide away after this one of
the things that that sort of kept me
going through that time it was you know
Brian inar the creative director on the
game he said look we're not going to you
know everybody who's who's making this
game love Spider-Man we're not going to
let you mess it up we're not g to let
you fail um also you have to remember
that uh there's so much to a game over
and above the performance performance is
one thing
but it's it's you know when when you
look at it such a small part of of the
whole but he can safely be like I'm over
here saying that as Brian like I not
going to con sitting in front of the
you're not going to get yeah I'm not
going to get tired and feathered if run
out of town if there's a certain face
value of playing Spider-Man right right
but I I honestly think like you know
you've played him for 10 years now which
is insane and I was looking back Madness
like Marvel pinball was 2013 Marvel
pinball Venom came out two years later
The Amazing Spider-Man 2 you played the
you were the mobile version of Andrew
Garfield's Amazing Spider-Man 2 which is
crazy to think about and then you went
on to do a bunch of voices in video
games and then adaptations in the live
action and the animation is there a
version of you that feels different in
your life because of playing Spider-Man
and vice versa how is your life informed
how you've played him over the 10 years
yeah it is a give and take uh it's
definitely informed who I am now it's
you know it's too big a part of my life
to to not be a part of it you know it's
it's interesting because I I didn't
realize this until recently just cuz it
keeps you know the whole idea of
responsibility keeps coming back you
know at you when you're when you play a
character like this oh my God you know
responsibility was was a big deal for my
dad like I could you know personal
responsibility was key and it was one of
those situations I think you know that
one of those things that happens as a
kid that you don't realize until much
later as an adult and it becomes like an
issue that go to therapy for like I
think I took that on too strongly I knew
it was important to my dad I wanted to
make my dad happy and so I I learned
early on a bad lesson about
responsibility which which is the more
responsibility I can take on the better
a person I'll
be uh which has made my life very
difficult U because you don't have to
here's what I'm learning now guess what
you don't have to be responsible for
everything right for everyone and taking
on responsibility for things that you
shouldn't be responsible for is not
necessarily a good thing doesn't equal
more power those two things don't rise
together no they do not it steals from
your power when you feel you have to be
responsible for everything you actually
have less power and I think that's the
lesson Peter has to learn over and over
again yeah and and you know because like
he feels that you know every single
person in New York City yeah he has to
protect them he has to take care of them
he can't you can't possibly do that but
he feels he has to I think that's the
big V diagram for me with Superman and
Spider-Man and I think that's why I love
Superman is once I discovered that he
has the same sensibilities as Spider-Man
where Spider-Man Spider Sense sometimes
he plays around with it to try to make
it stronger he wants to sense things
where they happen Superman's hearing
everything so both Superman and
Spider-Man are the two guys going like I
have to take care of a whole city and
I'm one guy and they have that weight of
them that isn't just punching M Leo
people in the face with your billions
like there's a different angle on it and
I think that the my issue with some
takes on Spider-Man is like the phrase
is with great power there must also come
responsibility and we cut it into with
great power comes it's an action yeah
like the verb is is taking on the
responsibility and I think a lot of
people miss out on the verbage of their
must also it's not inherent no yeah and
that is the original it's you know
that's been lost and I will occasionally
um you know somebody asked me to sign
something like will you write also um
the responsibility quote and I'm like
yes I will and I you know I write it
with great respon or with great power
must also come great responsibility the
full quote the the full quote as right
the
original yeah uh but but you're right it
informs it in a completely different way
I think it's important to draw that
distinction I think we both grew up
thinking it was the short one in our
heads and not because of the verbage but
I I agree I had the same I had like teen
parents so I had like we grew up like
having to do a lot but I do think that
it doesn't equal power and I think that
Spider-Man the reason I like the clone
saga is I see it as an existential
crisis it's when Peter's taking on so
much responsibility he makes a version
of himself that's blonde Fun Works in a
coffee shop has it all
going it's the Walkabout version of him
so I've always loved Ben because I see
it as a mental break for Peter like he
snaps and there's a Ben riy so I think
that like playing the version you've
done with the video game without the the
impact of the loss and all those things
and that's why I'm really curious about
the new game and again I don't want to
know anything about it but the idea of
playing this darker Spider-Man because
of the symbiot was there anything uh
that you brought because of your view of
responsibility that you're working
through that informed that well that's
yeah and I was going to bring that up
without spoiling anything uh the you
know one of the big differences you know
with with Peter when in in the new game
when he gets the suit is he has even
greater power and no responsibility what
what happens then and in the beginning
for Pete it's it's really exciting like
there's there's no downside he's got new
powers he's strong he's you know he's
like all this new cool stuff and all I
can think about is this makes me a
better Spider-Man yeah um but you know
we all know it does spoiler alert's one
spoiler comic right if read a comic the
symbiot suit does not end well for him
the dark suit is dark and things go
right yeah I mean you know he's he's
your friendly neighborhood Spider-Man to
try to get Peter to not be friendly like
I'd settled in such into such a an easy
place with Pete and like I know this and
I know Pete and I love Pete because you
know he's he's so kind and you know and
all that and to try to take him in the
opposite direction yeah was difficult it
was a lot more you know I was looking in
the beginning I was looking forward to
it because you know everybody wants to
play villain you know villains are fun
yeah but it was hard to make Peete do
those things even in my mind wow that's
awesome and I and I didn't realize it
until we we were doing it and at the end
of the day I was twice as tired as I
normally would be at the end of the day
I'm like what is am I sick am I you know
what's going on no it's just because
it's
so antithetical to who Peter always has
been you know as as the pure you know
original Peter that it was it was
difficult for me to even get him there I
love that like your inner turmoil as a
Spider-Man fan caused your exhaustion
playing Spider-Man exactly right like
that's not my peter you know I mean he
wouldn't do that yeah you know I don't
like saying these words this way it felt
like a lie yeah it's like the uh the
Todd McFarlene story about him making
the Venom Suit was basically because he
wanted him back in the red in the blue
like do you so to MC I so the black Su
again see again he's you are a bigger
Spider-Man fan than all of us so
Spider-Man was in the the black suit
from 252 Amazing Spider-Man 252 was
introduced in secret Wars number eight
but the first time it appeared in the
mainstream comic was Amazing Spider-Man
252 Venom doesn't appear until the last
frame of 299 so that everyone thinks the
first appearance is 300 it's actually
299 last panel todd'll tell you but
it's like Hulk 181 with if you really
want the
first so in the end of 299 Todd had only
taken over from 298 on so he' only done
one issue in the black suit and he
immediately was like I want to draw
Spider-Man I want to draw the webs I
want to draw in the red and blue the
reason Venom exists is because of him
wanting to get him out of that suit
quickly so he invented something to
throw venom on so the Venom Suit is
Eddie Brock existed he made him look all
awesome and Roy Mary Jane was obviously
the thing he was learing after but it
was all out of Todd wanting the spider
that you and I both that created Venom
so Todd writing the same thing of us
like he wouldn't do that so Venom exists
out of him the joyer back so it all
comes back to it's one big story quantum
theory I'm I'm just as smart intelligent
and as talented as Todd McFarland is
that what you're saying that's what I'm
saying I'm you to McFarland Stanley
right okay uh now I I personally see the
darkness of Venom as an important part
of of Spider-Man to go through kind of
like you know you have to go through
your trauma and that experience but with
your role as Sasuke I feel like there's
a certain parallel that informed this
take was there moments that you were
doing the the new take the voice and all
those things that you had flashbacks to
that cuz you ran that character for so
long yeah and still to to this day is
the longest character I've ever I'm
because I'm still recording Sasuke stuff
for games and Boro and you know all that
it was it certainly wasn't a conscious
thing but it was inevitable yeah because
of who Sasuke is and because he was the
first character that I really had to
sort of dig deep and mind you know
Darkness I mean before Sasuke all all
the characters that I played were you
know bright-eyed young Heroes you know
naive young Heroes and and then all of a
sudden you know Sasuke came along
because I've been playing him for so
long because such a popular
show people associate that stuff and and
they hear all voice they're like well
yeah but so as soon as they we dropped
that uh you know they at the the Sony uh
reveal the the Sony thing people were
immediately clocking that they're like
oh SAS now I know what it's going to
sound like
and and yeah here's the thing you know
it it wasn't it wasn't conscious I
wasn't thinking I need to put some S I
feel like this is the time to put some
but the crossover was
inevitable yes oh look at
that look look
everyone not planned at all also yeah
behind the scenes earlier we were
filming and not only did Greg have a g
fuel Sasuke but his phone case is
Spider-Man so we were looking at a SAS
Spider-Man combo and it was pretty
amazing which you know two of when when
I go to conventions now I think it's
it's pretty clear that those are my two
most popular characters I have I have
some other popular characters but none
like those two well I we I want to talk
about Sasuke benen and a few others
later but while while we're on Spidey
I's probably close third benen yeah he's
right there too yeah so I love love Tony
Todd like just the guy the voice his his
just Ness the first time for you as a
fan of not just Tony Todd but like
knowing what he could bring to Venom
what were your conversations like with
the idea of Tony Todd's Venom Brian
andar came he he uh came to one of the
the peap shoots that we were doing he's
he was he was there for most of them uh
but he comes up to me he's like I want
you to hear something he had his
phone and he goes listen to this it was
just a couple of things you know but it
was you know Tony's like we are Venom
you know and I'm like and I looked at
him he goes we got Tony Tod and I was
and I freaked out for you know for for a
number of different reasons one because
you know huge Fanboy and and I've Loved
Tony forever yeah but also because Tony
and I had just worked together for the
first time on Dota 2 dragon's blood for
for Netflix and we have basically the
same relationship in that show he's this
Dragon who mixes his blood to to survive
basically he mixes his blood with mine
and then I have this Dragon living
inside me and it's a very schizophrenic
sort of insane relationship and I'm like
oh my God are we doing this all over
again
and so luckily I'd gotten all my sort of
Fanboy energy out with him the first
time we work together exactly but but
he's also a huge nerd loves comic books
you know came in with and he's just so
cool I mean you know guy like and I
think that the hard thing with Tony is
that because of the characters he's
played and the characters we love him
for we approach him with this you know
fear you know honestly like he's a
theater kid like I love that he's like
Candyman exterior but he's like ah he's
so theatrical yeah he's and it still
does a lot of you know theater you kudos
to that guy he's so kind and so cool you
know and so funny in real life that it's
you have to do the sort of this mind
flip you know you it's always the nicest
guys totally it's always fascinating to
me I I love that Tony Todd is our Venom
but I also got to give credit to Naji
who is Miles like he is Miles he's so
good I met him at that signing you guys
had for the first time and he like
exuded such miles energy I was like oh I
see this this just makes sense with his
uh miles aging and growing and all those
things did you guys have conversations
about the difference in your
relationship and did you guys have
offscreen relationship conversations
like is that Bond likewise on screen and
on it is it is very similar our our
relationship in the game is very similar
to our real life relationship which
worked out great and we could not have
called that you know he was he's he's
much younger than me you know he was a
you know younger actor when we started
he would come to me you know with
questions sometimes I mean you know he's
super he's far more talented than me um
which is you know but just you know with
les with less experience and so it was
interesting to to be playing that
because we never had to play at it yeah
I mean one of my favorite uh scenes from
that first game is when when Spidey
teaches miles to fight in the alley like
I just I just love that scene I remember
when we were doing that scene and I
don't know it's just been you know it's
been fun to you know to to watch him
grow up and come into his power much
like miles you there a lot and to you
know to a point where like we've seen
over the games over the last you know
from from the first game to the miles
game to this game um see Spidey go you
know see Pete go I don't need to I don't
need to be your Mentor anymore like you
like not only do you have this but you
know you might have this more than me
you know I I love how miles has become
such a a cultural Ze guy shift in comics
and Legacy characters because a lot of
times Legacy characters have like a run
they got like a 5e round like they're
popular miles like if you look at the
the resale value of comics miles is he
like a stronger hold than Peter Parker
in the last 10 years miles is selling
more like variant covers and everything
Peter Parker and and miles is so many
people Spider-Man and I love that he
gets to embody a character that is him
in so many ways while it's like at the
height of everything yeah that is Magic
and I and I forget I think it was a
writer I think it might have been a
comic book writer uh said this on
Twitter and I wish I could remember who
it was maybe you will remember the
comment uh you probably will I'm glad
I'm talking to you about it but he said
something along the lines of you know
when I when when kids hear you know when
when people today hear
Spider-Man most you know most of this
generation thinks of Miles like they
don't think of Peter and they think of
Peter as oh that old Spider-Man with the
terrible jokes like that I've never
thought are funny it's the bar Allen
Wally West thing it's it's like at some
point Wally West is a lot of people's
Flash and it's really fascinating it's
not like conell or super boy Super Boy
where it just like oh that was a moment
yeah right it's an evolution of a
character that people obviously still
need and want it's it's a testament to
the enduring nature of of Spider-Man
there it doesn't the Spider-Man doesn't
have to go away because you need
something new you just make something
new out of Spider-Man for for you know
that generation and the different like
Shmi and Naji play him so differently
and it also shows how archetypal miles
is because I love that they're not doing
the same character and just like your
Peter and Tom's they're not the same
person but they are Spider-Man yeah yeah
I love I love the game I can't wait uh
last can't for to play I can't wait I'm
going to live
at the time that we're recording it's
like 20 days away and it like I just
want it to happen already I I like the
fact that I know less than 5% is more
exciting than I can quantify because
this job I know so much about movies
when I see them I know so much about
shows I know the actors but this game
I'm like I get to live we've been it's
because we don't have Tom Holland work
on this
production
Venom Tom we love you uh but I also want
to briefly talk about our across the
spiderverse experience uh be my last bit
of Spidey stuff then want to dive into
audience they like nase uh
so they like I'm going to fix it they
like Sasuke I Gotta Give time right I
heard myself say Naruto Sasuke and nase
they like Sasuke their time now we saw
the spiderverse together thank you I
felt it we saw across the spiderverse
together and I had the most interesting
time watching it the first time without
you and then watching it my second time
with you because the first time I
watched it I watched it with a giant
crowd of like
movie fans and there were certain pops
but watching it with you there were
Spider-man pops and there were a bunch
of times when we both like actually
stood up cuz we were talking to to Lord
Miller at the end they knew where we
were sitting because of our yells so I
remember specifically they like
referenced us getting jokes that other
people had and with that viewing
experience are there moments when you
watch other mediums of the character you
play when you feel like your peter is in
that Universe like did you have that
like I'm cuz you physically are in the
movie did you think of where Peter would
be running around across the spiderverse
while being enveloped in a world not so
because I was so taken with the movie
like I could not I could not think a
back or aead sure I was just taking it
in you know our Earth 1048 Spider-Man is
part of that you know special team but
it's spider cop yes but he's you know
he's talking like spider cop I mean
clearly in his line it's it's not a very
spider cop delivery but I love the idea
that they got they chose him because
he's a cop so good because he's a
detective yeah a spider cop in the edge
running the spider first exactly exactly
cuz the whole time I watched it the
fourth time I was like okay where would
I imagine that Spider-Man like I was
planting like Miguel would like that guy
like he would hate he would hate he
would hate you know that that that Peter
but he'd love and maybe he made a
mistake like he's like I thought I was
getting spider cup and then this guy
shows up and he's like I'm not really
you know he been Riley of that like he's
just like this isn't what I wanted I'm
so sorry
made a horrible mistake I've recruited
incorrectly I saw cop I got excited uh
now you also have another giant property
coming out right now I think it came as
of filming it came out a week ago as of
releasing it's probably about a month
but Mortal Kombat is another giant zeit
guy shift in video games and smoke is
one of the Ninjas in this insane lore
who did you call first what was it like
finding out like what was the experience
of knowing you're in Mortal Kombat well
the the the crazy thing for me about
Mortal Kombat is is I wasn't a big
Mortal Kombat player going into it so I
didn't have a lot of the attachments
that I like when I got Spider-Man it was
one thing when I got Mortal Kombat now
look who doesn't know what Mortal Kombat
is and you know I'm I'm old enough to
you know have been pumping quarters into
you know cabinet video games and I I
remember Mortal Kombat but it wasn't a
game that I that I played what it was it
was the first of many faux pods like
when I showed up to the you know when we
started the first uh recording session
for it I'm like so so tell me about this
new character smoke and and you know and
I really cuz cuz I just you know I was I
was a little I was a little more
clueless on this front and Dominic
chancho who was the the writer on on on
the project and who directed all the the
the voiceover sessions that I was in I
was like okay let me uh let me correct
you there smook is not a new character
we haven't seen him in a while but he's
not a new character uh but thankfully
he's a ninja and I've played ninjas
before so familiar right um I but you
know maybe maybe it was good because you
know I didn't have a view of who who I
thought I should you know sort of stick
to and you know make him into you know
what went before yeah so I just worked
with with Dominic to create you know the
smoke for this game I love that that's
the opposite experience in real time as
Spider-Man like the most dedicated could
not be more invested in what he's been
to you and like this guy right do you
have a favorite fatality or anything
while you were developing the character
that you were like oh he's going to do
this and the surprise you having you had
experience I mean the surprise for me
was that you know we recorded a you know
a variety of different sort options and
then I think they built the fatalities
and then sort of pieced together all the
different horrible sounds you know that
that that we made um so I didn't know
what they were going to be in advance so
actually I got to play it for like the
first time a week ago and uh and it was
it was it was fun finally getting to see
some of that stuff because I mean that's
you know I may not have been a huge
Mortal Kombat guy but we it's still
Mortal Kombat I still used the song from
the you know the the what is it 1995 oh
yeah uh movie 196 movie to uh to wake up
to in the morning like I said it it was
it was like I had my first like clock
radio that you could actually choose a
song on a CD wasn't just what came on
you know on the on the radio and I chose
the theme song to that movie because it
just it just got me fired oh it's my
workout mixes always like that makes the
C there's like the blade soundtrack
Matrix that there's certainly like
techno 2000s yeah yeah now Mortal Kombat
is a a formative bit of that same era of
childhood but I'm going to go a little
bit more to our presence uh you and I I
mean I visited but I was so enamored
with orbital Redux man like orbital
Redux was such a cool future you were
there at the beginning yeah you really
were I got to see like that world come
together and it was insane yeah so you
got to build a character that had to be
flexible enough to improv that much but
had to have a foundation enough that
characters were endeared to them and
viewers related to them what was it like
developing a character that had to be
three disperate things that you had to
live in for that long I'd love you for
bringing this up cuz cuz I you know cuz
because of the nature of the platform
not a lot of people got to see it and
yet it's probably that the highest tight
RPP I've ever walked as a performer you
know it was it was a live weekly Sci-Fi
show that we were doing for legendary
when they when they had their Alpha
platform and everything was was like it
was you know it was like a 20-minute
show sci-fi all the all the effects were
happening in real time all the camera
work was you know all the cutting was
was live all the the music was being
performed by a band on the stage we were
doing it as if that weren't you know
more you know difficult enough we we let
the chat sometimes decide things yeah we
would have to sort of pivot on real time
onet sometimes it was it was it was you
know full improv and then we'd sort of
get back to the story you know get back
to the script because we did have a
story we wanted to tell and we weren't
just going to let them you know come up
with everything uh but but sometimes we
had several like branching parts of the
the script uh and we had to prepare all
of them and then we'd let the audience
choose and then right before we went
live you know we we we took the poll and
they're like okay we're going with you
know you know Branch 3 yeah and we'd all
have to sort of reset our brains as to
what that meant I don't know how we did
I I'm glad it's out there on on Dust you
can watch it on YouTube um and just
remember if if you're watching it now
remember that it's uh that when we were
doing that was live 2018 yeah it was it
was it was right about the time
Spider-Man came out okay yeah that's
right so yeah 2018 18 and we I went to a
visit set and it would basically be them
gathering for about 10 minutes the
director doing like a walkr to make sure
things were physically there and then
everything was like a play that was
happening in real time every day that
changed yeah it was it was all it all
came in in rehearsal and you know
staging and all that and and correct me
if I'm wrong but didn't you see that
that sort of sneak preview thing that we
did down at ComicCon were you down at
the geek and sunry thing it was like a
interview with the character and a fake
interviewer um that before people even
knew what the show was and it was
amazing because you guys all had to be
in character but also be just as
flexible yeah because that was the other
the day you guys shot the the launch and
then we did that all that stuff in the
actual capsule for interviews and
everything right and I'm wondering how
your improv obviously you've had the
Improv ability with all of the years of
video game and animation which are a lot
more improv heavy but how has the Improv
in real time changed how you approach
characters since you know I'm you know
I'm a theater kid from from way back and
you know I've studied improv and we
don't get to use that so much in video
games and animation because so much
there's so much that we're not privy to
about how that works that us improving
could [__] all that up like sure it
could you know we could improv and if
they had to keep it they'd be like yeah
but we've already storyboarded all you
know all this so so actually that's
that's pretty a lot of it's pretty rigid
but it did come in handy in in
Spider-Man I I hate to go back to
Spider-Man sorry it's man it's going to
that because when I first started I mean
he you know the writing is so great you
don't you don't need to improv with with
writing that great but as I got more and
more comfortable with the character I
would get ideas yeah which was sometimes
dangerous you know for for them um and
you'd have to sort of read the room you
know how many lines we have to get
through that day do I have time to say
hey can I get one more and here's a quip
I just thought of sure or whatever they
after a while you know I felt
comfortable doing that and they felt
comfortable trusting me and they didn't
always use whatever I came up with cuz
you know it wasn't always good and
sometimes they were like yeah that was a
hilarious you know 30 second ad lib you
just did but this is combat and it
needed to be two seconds so sorry we
can't only use words yeah it was
hilarious and we're burning it yeah no
one will ever hear it but we liked it
thanks yeah but I you know I've always
loved I think everybody should have to
take improv because it just makes you
confident it just you know in in any
situation being able to to to Pivot and
you know figure out you know what the
game of any situation is now in the
world of liveaction you've been on some
iconic shows like Gilmore Girls and I
did not realize uh another favorite of
mine Chef Carl dude Gilmore Girls is so
language heavy so the idea of like impr
profitable Reb back to Gilmore Girls but
also Alias man I didn't realize you were
on Alias until this week that made me so
happy but is there any other live action
sandbox you haven't gotten to play in
that you want to is there like a genre
or a type of thing I mean I love you
know I I love movies and TV so much that
there there isn't there's hardly a
sandbox that I wouldn't want to play in
but you know I I'm I'm an unabashed you
know genre TV and film guy like if if
you said you you'll never be able to
watch you know serious serious you know
shows again you have to you know just
stick with genre Stu be like okay you
know you know I'll miss I'll miss the
bear but you know like like like that's
you know like that's i l 5% of my
content right right right exactly you
know for for for the longest time I was
like I was like I want to be the first
you know American actor to play the
doctor o like you know cuz I grew up I
grew up watching Doctor Who like you
know you know Tom Baker was my guy and I
I used to go to I mean those were the
first like conventions that I went to I
went to Star Trek conventions I went to
doctor who conventions and I still I
still have I have all the all the
doctors through Sylvester McCoy I have
their autographs except for who was the
for the the first harnell uh William
harnell I think was am I is that is that
we got nods yeah okay yeah cuz hard was
already dead by the time I uh you know I
I I started watching um and I have all
the original cast of Star Trek except
for uh what's that guy Bill Bill Bill
Shatner
oh right exactly it's two two two bills
two bills bill bill harell and Bill
Shatner I've just loved this stuff for
so much it's always fired me up you know
comic books and and movies you know
fantasy and horror and I'd love to I I
kind of feel like I'm like I'm in my
Elijah Wood like phase where all where
just all I want to do is is make like
indie horror movies with my friends him
and Dan re made the Right Moves man
right make the tries make the money and
then live and then just do what you love
the most which he clearly does you know
Pon too I feel like P doesn't quite get
the credit cuz he's like he's the IND
intense darling Patterson had me uh with
with the at the Rover yeah it was my
favorite movie that year and I'm like
wait a minute that's that guy yeah guy
Pier is a force and he's like acting
circles around Guy Pierce like that guy
I could not believe it and then you know
good time and the lighthouse and his
Batman like I feel like that all shaped
the Bruce Wayne he made yeah yeah you
can yeah yeah without a doubt so I went
through the 800 credits uh you have
amassed as of Spider-Man 2 a very polite
way of saying that I'm old 8 no not 800
credits 800 credits insane but I'm going
to go personal for a minute I want to
know a mix of personal and professional
okay uh proposing in a ch- Chee parking
lot ch- Chee is a restaurant that I
adore very much that is amazing salsa do
they still have them anywh uh there are
a couple in New England that I know of
as a pre- pandemic but Chi salsa I still
buy I don't know if restaurants still
going but ch- and then driving cross
country impromptu and then deciding
while driving cross country to just go
ahead and get married after the surprise
engagement in Vegas after midnight yeah
and still with this wonderful woman now
with an awesome kid is there any
character you've played that's that
romantic I think the real me is more
romantic than any character I've ever
played I went through 800 credits and I
was like who I couldn't find one I
looked because I was like that's cuz the
the chi thing and like man you guys get
in Vegas so you could argue you know a
deep deep uh uh anime um but dur is a
show in which I played a character named
Shinra kishani on and he's this uh he's
hor he's he's he's a terrible romantic
um and he's he's adorable but also super
twisted like he he he's he's in love
with this with this spirit this she uh
like an Irish uh you know Spirit named
named selty and you you find out later
that he's been hiding her head so that
she sort of stays with him
wow um yeah it's it's again it's he's
he's super romantic but also really
really weird that is so heavy that is a
very in uh now also on the personal side
you played Ben 10 for years and I do
want to talk about Ben 10 but your kid
is also approaching the age of OG Ben 10
that's true so what is it like seeing
your kid approach the age of a character
whose voice you've done and how does
that reframe how you see that
demographic in your head I have loved
using my son to go back and Revis visit
uh like animation and like things that
that I either didn't get to and now I
have an excuse or you know that I that I
you know that I want to go and finish or
that that I never got to do or to to
even look at my own work uh I have I've
done a pretty good job so far at edging
him into the things like I I was afraid
that if I pushed him into all the nerdy
things that I liked that he would
immediately Rebel and i' be like oh no
you know um but I think I've done a
pretty good job of cuz he he watches we
just started watching Naruto together
from the very beginning which I've never
done before and it's been he loves it
benen we've been watching for the last
couple years and he loves like if he
could be benen and you know to your to
your question to your point I mean we
all want to be Ben 10 gen whether it's
related or not yeah but but if he loves
that but then I was using him using him
using my son using my son to be big
bigger nerd was like oh yeah I never you
know I never really got got to watch
Gargoyles the show like when it was so
we went back and we started watching
gargoyles and I'm like oh thank God he's
here they gave me an excuse to like
start at the beginning and just you know
watch and Samurai Jack I'm like I never
finished Samurai you know like all these
shows and and you know sort of watch and
arguably they're at times you know more
for me than they are for him but luckily
he's been okay with it um yeah I love it
I I love that I'm hopefully I'm kind of
raising a genre kid he likes things that
are scary but not too scary you know and
he loves you know Naruto and Ben and
Spider-Man he just we started playing
Spider-Man together which is which is
good cuz I may be able to erase the
shame I'm I'm famously uh you know like
3% at the game and walked
away um and so so now I think I'm like
15% playing playing it with him so so we
may we may actually get to the end and
and he will be the reason that I do so I
want to make sure I get this this name
of the place right but I when I look at
Voice work so much of it in my head
comes from meeting people and the actual
Act of living and seeing how people
communicate and if I have the timeline
right I think you were the coordinator
of English relations as part of the
Japanese exchange and teaching program
before you decided to be a teacher and
then before you decided to be an actor
at all do you look back on that time and
the way you analytically looked at
communication as something that informed
how you got into Voice work and how you
perceive language I told you not to get
smart with me
course it seems so one and zero to me
did that help inform though like vo
feels like a very similar parallel yeah
I mean again I think you know a lot of
people are like what what should I do
like I want to be an actor you know
should I do what classes should I take
and I'm like well it's great to take
classes but you also got to go I find
that uh interesting people who lead
interesting lives make interesting
actors and so you can't just limit it to
I know a lot of people who are like I'm
in all the classes and I'm doing all the
work I'm like yeah but you got to got to
go and live a life um you got to have
stories to tell and you've got to you've
got to see the world and I grew up my my
dad was in the Foreign Service he was
with USA and so we we grew up traveling
a lot and my mom you know was not
originally from this country and so you
know I had family elsewhere and I I just
assumed that I
would even after I fell in love with
acting I assumed that that wasn't you
know like a a job that I could do um
then I would probably go into the family
business and I was sort of in in you
know on an international relations track
and and I had fallen in love with Japan
and so so I went to Japan and I and I
thought this was and I was loving it you
know I mean it was it was everything
that I had hoped and and yet there were
surprises every day but I I just wasn't
jelling with the with the you know the
the bureaucracy of the job that I had
over there I went over on the jet
program the Japan exchange and teaching
program but because I had already been
studying Japanese and I had already done
my junior year abroad in Japan they gave
me this yeah coordinator for
international relations uh position and
while I loved that it got me to Japan I
found that you know I I was sitting in a
room and this was this was you know the
the early or you know mid 90s I was I
was in offices where people still
smoking like all the WoW you know like
it was this was it was a bureaucratic
the computers were a million years old
and I I was I was loving my work and I
was loving what I was doing but but it
was you know it was it was it was too
bureaucratic I had already fallen in
love with acting at that last year of
high school and it just would not
wouldn't leave that it wouldn't leave
and I I would I would get out of work
every day and I'd go off and you know do
stuff with Japanese theater companies or
Australian theater companies or you know
I'd make stupid movies with my friends
you know who were there because
digital you know video had gotten to a
place where you could you could afford
to get a camera and and make movies and
and I I realized that I had to I had to
go try I didn't want to look back in 30
years and you know this bureaucratic
where where I had also started smoking
you know could have been an act new yor
um and I thought you know this this work
will will be here if if like if I go and
it's just horrible yeah um and I and I
never looked back I I moved to New York
and I and honestly I see languages I
mean like living language is so
important and I do think mean you being
fluent in four languages it really
informs how voice over can tie in and
well again you never know how how the
experiences that you have in life will
affect the path like you're like well
learning Japanese is not going to it's
not going to help me get a job in the
entertainment industry you know like
it's a very sort of specific thing you
use it for this and not everybody needs
to do that but it was part of my path
because the you don't you don't need to
know Japanese even to do dubbing but it
helped give me an extra layer of when
they would play the Japanese before we
would do the English I was catching you
know a lot of the original language and
intonations and and then because a
coordinator from my anime work was the
same coordinator they asked to uh to
help cast uh sort of Japanese smaller
characters and background characters on
this uh Teen Titans trouble in Tokyo Arc
that they did she brought me in because
she knew I spoke Japanese even though I
was the only white guy in the room yeah
that got me over at Warner Brothers and
then the next time I was at Warner
Brothers was was playing Superman on
Legion superheroes
and you couldn't you couldn't have
planned that and that's that's the point
I think you can't plan anything you just
got to you got to live and follow you
know your joy I think people not like
following a certain path but following
paths is the way to get to like a fun
fulfilled life especially creatively
yeah uh and I got to speed around a few
because they're they're wrapping us out
but you have played can can we can we
can we can we just agree right now that
this will be like part one oh yeah I
think so cuz I got I mean I press five
hours I'm not even kidding this is a
third of what even I cut down to well
then I want I want you I want you to
make me the guy that when your guest is
like at the last minute they're like I'm
sorry my cat's on fire whatever you know
whatever it is y there's a cat on fire
in I need you to go save the cat first
and then can you come in because OB jug
water and also to cuz yeah I didn't get
to Afro Samurai which I'm a huge fan of
uh I definitely want to talk about Swan
Princess briefly though so we have a
first ad here the huge Swan Princess fan
so I've got to know and this this
actually made me I I'm invested when you
have a director of something like Swan
Princess is it like a metal band where
the most scary guy is the friendliest or
is recording something like Swan
Princess hell uh he was no it was it
wasn't opposites like like like the
director is one of the kindest like
sweetest you know men you know I've ever
met uh funny uh Swan Princess trivia uh
in the one of the most recent I think it
is the at this time the most recent Swan
Princess movie that we did they were
looking for for a certain you know
series of scenes that are flashback
they were looking for a 5-year-old
version of my character and the casting
director reached out to me and he said I
don't know if you'd consider this um but
we know you have a 5-year-old son do you
think he'd be interested in reading and
I'm like I you know that's you know both
both Tara and I have have made sure that
we we we never want to push like Sean
into entertainment you know but we're
also like he's you know he's he's he's
super funny and uh you know loves stuff
and and we we sort of put it we laid it
out to him we're like hey buddy you know
this this stuff like this may come up
and if you feel like you want to do it
if it sounds like fun to you you know do
it but if it but if it's some if it's if
it's not fun then look we don't have any
stake in this but he he read and and he
was adorable and they cast him and so in
that movie the younger version of me is
actually played by my real life son that
is beautiful now since then since then
every now and then I'll be like hey
buddy an audition came in for you uh do
you want to do it he's like I'm playing
Legos and I'm like awesome good you're
also still a kid this is very important
to me exactly and occasionally he'll
he'll be like yeah that sounds like fun
um but it's been uh it's yeah that's
beautiful right we're going to do Sasuke
and Ben 10 next time we're going to do a
lot of the back in the day but I have
one final I have to ask question and
then the the show title itself but You'
played Leonardo oh that's the name of
the show that's the it's a good question
that's why that's up there I got a
couple sarcastic Goods in there but uh
so we had we got Leonardo we got
Donatello we got Michelangelo you have
not yet played rapael not yet you played
three of the four turtles yeah which
which you know how nerdy I am it is a
big it's a big deal for me I'm wondering
do you have a goal are you trying to
manifest because I read that you dressed
as the Son of Batman at Batman 1989's
Premiere and manifested playing him
later on are you trying to manifest
Raphael right now with this leather
jacket
cuz
I I don't know anybody else has played
three of four turtles right right yeah
what's what's like is Nick Cage in that
Club Nick we need you to play Rafael
fight Yuri to the death uh yeah no I
have like I feel like I have to you know
I mean here's the thing I mean my voice
doesn't tend toward I mean but but then
you know Sasuke yeah I mean so you could
argue that Sasuke is the rapael of right
um yeah no I'll I'll always angle for it
but there are always people who tend
more easily towards that like I'll
always want play Batman but let's be
honest I'll play Robin you know like I
mean that's few that's yeah right that
that'll that's that's more you know
towards towards you know in in the zone
but yeah that's you know it's it's just
another you know nerdy like yeah check
mark yeah from you know play all turtles
H yeah it's I I have that sort of mental
list and every time I get to you know
play a character that I grew up with
that I that I loved that has you know
like a you know sort of like a a pop
culture you know just the history is is
always extra special for me in a way
that might not always appeal to every
actor you know they might not sense it
in a way they're like oh yeah I'll play
that you know sure not all yeah well
next time I want to focus on DC animated
because we actually just rewatched uh
like 30 of the 50 DC animated films uh
we're going through on this channel and
going through all of them so we're we're
going to be talking all the time yeah
definitely part two through seven it's
going to be like an evening with Kevin
Smith this is the new Hall age right I
love it I'm so much more comfortable
here than I am in Hall age and and I
don't have to stand on the table for you
that's true I mean we've already done
the dance so we'll save it for episode
four I'll come up get the people back
we're like guys you guys have a wide
angle yeah that's what it's for but uh
the the theme of this show is great
questions and I think that the most
human thing is communication I think the
internet has made communication uh more
prevalent but less common uh and I love
the idea of positing questions that kind
of open people up is there a question
that philosophically changed you or any
question that you want to POS it to
someone else that you feel like would
open something up in them that you've
experienced in your
life you should have prepared me for
this one that's um I'm a big believer in
kindness and the and the and the power
of
kindness and we we live in a in a world
today where that's not where it's not
always seen as a power or a strength
strength is is a very specific
thing um and I guess my
question has to be at this point as you
know someone who still you know clings
to that as something that's
important um and truly you know
transformative
is do people I mean
is is is
kindness more important than like brute
strength or power like can can a kind
person you know
win
over the you know the the the things
that we see out there right now all the
all the big you know demons out there is
kindness truly powerful enough
to to to to fight that and to win wow
that's I was not Spider-Man uh I think
that's thematically this episode I think
that's kind of Peter Parker's whole
thing right yeah yeah I I think that's
that's very it's very not Raphael but
very Spider-Man I'll take it I'll take
the reason why you haven't played it yet
it all comes back but dude absolute
pleasure man this is I cannot wait play
the game I feel like that's going to be
we can do a whole episode on DC but also
then after I've played the game like
that the oh yeah like like you know at
least seven more episodes I cannot
fathom uh how much it must feel like a
great power and great responsibility
because there must also come great
responsibility with power but uh thank
you
foring that Spider-Man you you've been
very responsible with how important he
is to us so thank you for wielding that
power responsible it means the world man
thank you Coy it means the world that uh
that after knowing each other for so
long we get to hang out like this yeah
Yeah we actually got we talking about
this for I think we talking about this
for the better part of a decade they
like we should do that long form thing
yeah I know we did we go much love
reject nation that is going to do it for
Yuri's first of seven episodes we'll be
back to discuss so much more and I love
that question man I think kindness is a
a lost art but it is the greatest
superpower I I don't care about flight
or telekinesis or invisibility if you're
kind you're a hero and uh it's important
to just do that we did to quote at May
from the first game when you help
someone you help everyone there it is no
better ending much love you lovelies